foreign
[Music]
ERS yoga teacher girlfriend whatever she
keeps smiling at me can you tell her to
stop smiling at me yes I will tell Dad's
girlfriend to stop smiling at you that
won't cause any issues also I cannot sit
at the table with Tom's mother on a boat
here she tried to start a sing-along to
South Pacific she's excited okay she's
never been out of the country before
not with Carol gonna watch that man
right out of my hair I'm gonna wash that
man right out of my hair and send him on
his way
I've been looking forward to this moment
ever since baby Tommy was cut out of my
abdomen oh my God I have never been on a
private island before I've never been
even on an island before actually you
know what that's not true I what were
the Hebrew memes we went to Mackinac you
know before they moved to Bloomington
heck you would have been to Mackinaw
Renata I don't know what that is or most
of the words you just said the only
reason I agreed to a traditional wedding
was because you said that we'd have
moments alone
Carol
hi hello
your future mother-in-law Carol yep I
know your name Carol I brought some of
the extras for the welcome bags in case
you want to make one for Sean oh oh
great thanks
all right thanks call me
you're not wearing any pants
I just want to ask and I hope it's okay
is that genetics
or is it like Pilates oh Mom now's not
the time my name
is Carol Elaine Fowler
and I deserve to live
Carol
what are you doing I'm humanizing myself
I saw it on Good Morning America if you
humanize yourself to them
they let you live
I am a wife
I am a mother and I was Milford
Michigan's top realtor in 1998
and again in 2007
I dreamed of going to Ireland
I was a late bloomer and my teeth didn't
come in till I was 14.
he's picked me
[Music]
I'm from Brazil
I have a beautiful hair
[Music]
what else
you're a mother
I'm a mother
Pikachu oh
[Music]
Darcy I am so honored to Bear witness to
the sacred observance of Reaper and
devotion
[Music]
Renata
I need to go to the latest one
hey me too when I'm in formal wear I
like to be standing up how about you
you doing okay Jamie
my stomach feels like it's gonna fall to
my but I don't want to sound
chilly listen it's normal to feel scared
I'm not gonna let anything happen to you
or your family I promise
hey Sean
I am also feeling scared like the most
scared I've ever been in my whole life
it's like I just watched the ring you
know
so as some of you may know Didi and I
were 100 years ago we're engaged
but she called it off
no no no no no no
she was waiting for Tom
and that guy right there has got to be a
one in a million Supernova to snag that
beautiful soul
so in conclusion I just want to say one
thing to you DD
ukachi
[Laughter]
honey maybe we should just call it a
night you go ahead I gotta finish these
centerpieces and rearrange the seating
chart yes
hello Mom now is not the time I just
want to ask is that genetics or is it
like Pilates
you got your gift If You're Something
Borrowed brings you good luck except for
Uncle Greg who ended up decapitated on
that forklift but that's not the knives
fall oh someone just left that in the
bathroom
horn Safari you forgot to put his shirt
all the way up
is it time for dinner
you look so much better than the rest of
us I think the left food is slightly
lower than the right food something
doesn't feel right
[Applause]
here's the plan
spray him in the ice
won't work why so many steps
not once did I wonder
if I'd be walking handcuffed Through the
Jungle with a live grenade
oh you got it I got it you got it okay
[Music]
we're gonna fix this
that just growing on me I wanted
something less traditional
nobody with my family
[Music]
[Applause]
Carol thank you for the cake knife
foreign
[Music]